we've come here with a question
after all this time after so many dead
how do we still not know where it came
from
this is many scientists best guess so
far
yunnan province in southwest china these
mountains hide caves and these caves
hide bats
and those bats carry coronaviruses
we're heading for a mine shaft where the
closest known relative of sarsko v2
the virus that causes kovind 19 was
discovered after three miners died of
pneumonia-like symptoms in 2012.
but we're not welcome a car blocks the
road
china has always said it has acted
openly and transparently when it comes
to covid19 well this is a sort of
openness and transparency you tend to
find when you come to these places
is what any investigation into the
origins of the virus is up against
more men come more blocked roads
more blank stares
we try a different route a car follows
us the entire way
until we're stopped by the police lying
in wait for us
this is a system that doesn't care for
questions
and it is one that the experts from the
world health organization must navigate
they arrive today in wuhan covid ground
zero
and will spend two weeks in strict
quarantine
the scientists will visit the wet market
responsible for the largest initial
covet cluster
absent from the official itinerary
though is this
the wuhan institute of virology
researchers there handled coronaviruses
in the lab
but have denied any possibility of a
leak
and china denies more than that for
months the government has been promoting
theories that the virus originated
elsewhere
does the chinese government agree that
the most likely
country work over 19 originated is still
china
so one of the pieces of evidence for
that theory comes from this researcher
who discovered covid in samples from
italian patients as far back as
september 2019
before the first outbreak in china but
if it is true that some
cases were positive in october or
september
it means that the virus circulated much
earlier than
expected and what known and maybe it
means that
the original the virus was different the
only one thing
that i can say according to this kind of
information
is that the virus circulated
in china much earlier than december
it will be a long winding way to the
truth
and there is no assurance it will ever
be found
tom cheshire sky news yunnan south west
china